it's time for roses and rose AI have ice
in my Rosie it's August stop judging
it's pretty much mostly melted at this
point but hydration is key so let's
start off with it
that felt like drowning oh you guys
bachelor in paradise blew my mind
literally this week the entire episode
felt like deja vu deja vu
the strange feeling but in some way you
have already experienced what is
happening now yep
anyway so Ashley eyes crying over Jared
again take the red pill take the blue
pill I don't know matrix records even
though in this very room
Daniel is making uncomfortable jokes
about sleeping with a virgin why is
sleeping at a virgin good
the twins are literal visual deja vu
they're the same person and they only
count as one Rose a Lee and I are two
three one Rose and then three new guys
came in and they all looked exactly the
same and we couldn't remember any of
their names sorry it's so bad well
that's his name Bret Ryan Carl Bret Ryan
they sound like a politician I'm best
remembered the guys the sounds for not
really being remembered back to the plot
we know that Jared and Kayla have been
getting along really well but Kayla gets
asked out on a date by Brett and then we
have more deja vu because girl can't
decide if she wants to go or not
let's go wait no more from Daniel he's
calling himself papa bear big papa bear
who else used to call themselves a bear
that's right Chad Chad will never leave
this show you won't ever leave it he's
here forever
Chad bear may but here's what's really
going to blow your mind do you want to
take the red pill or do you want to take
the blue pill the constants have totally
changed while we were hearing the same
things over and over again from Ashley I
and from Kayla we know and from Daniel
Papa Bear what changed
were the people who we thought we're
gonna stay consistent grant and lace
gave us one up because Grant said I love
you and then in episodes and give us a
serious down because looks like they're
gonna have problem so maybe I should
break up with him and then busy well
it's honestly not something I was
expecting either this was heartbreaking
I'm actually tearing up a little bit and
that's a lot for me I don't cry yeah so
Vinny and Izzy Izzy was just like Kayla
what do you do my hair stylist
captivated by Bret and when Bret walked
in this morning and she's been getting
on really well with Minnie this whole
time but she told Vinnie oh I think I
want to explore this with Brett and his
Carly put it best this is just about
looks Vinnie who I freaking love was
heartbroken and said he was about to cry
Vinnie so the episode ended on a
cliffhanger what will happen with Vinny
and Izzy what will happen with Grant and
lace we don't know one thing we do know
jared is not into Ashley I are you sure
you don't want to lose me
Ashley's having the hardest time
accepting this and I gotta given it
credit NIC Val has been like the most
hilarious storyteller of this season
ashley was actually kicked off after the
rose ceremony then asked to come back
and here was Nick's reaction yeah just
cheered general cheers - Nick you know I
need a drink or something that's so cold
that your teeth hurt yeah worth it
though I also have some kind of
throwback thoughts this episode cuz you
guys remember when kayla was supposed to
maybe be the Bachelorette and then it
turned out to be Jojo now I feel like
we're maybe seeing why kayla is pretty
indecisive and I think I'm gonna stay
here and pretty not good at explaining
her feelings thinks feelings are
complicated and pretty uncomfortable in
a lot of situations that might be why I
get it all of this all of this deja vu
all of this all of this deja vu and not
deja vu the same things happening and
things changing people who we think are
in love imploding that is bachelor in
paradise and it's amazing I absolutely
love this episode what did you guys
think let me know over on Twitter and be
sure to subscribe to e t--'s youtube
channel because i'm here with my icy
cold alcoholic beverages every single
week this is such a risky move I don't
have the athletic ability or the
hand-eye coordination for this I think
it's only working because I'm a little
bit tipsy
let's really get daring that's really
good Terry I am amazing we are in the
matrix guys thanks so much for watching
have a great night who would who would
neo give his rose to again Ashley I I
think she needs somebody weird